[Musik]
hallo mein Name ist Luca und herzlich
willkommen heute zu einer neuen Episode
Skyblock mit Luca
[Musik]
der
stand da als ich in die Welt
reingegangen bin noch nicht aber wir
nehmen es gerne in Kauf denn Holz kann
natürlich nie schaden ich werde ihn auch
tatsächlich direkt abbauen denn wir
dürfen auch heute leider wieder gar
nicht lange Zeit verlieren denn es gibt
einiges zu tun heute und ich glaube wir
werden heute wieder nicht mit den ganzen
To-Dos fertig die ich mir für heute
vorgenommen habe ich bau mal eben kurz
hier so ein paar Blöcke rum sofern es
halt geht um alles Mögliche was hier
runter droppt also respektive Setzlinge
primärerweise einfach auch einsammeln zu
können die Sache ist dass wir für heute
wieder extrem viel auf der To-Do-Liste
haben ich lass den Baum sich jetzt
einfach mal die spawnen oder fällt er
direkt schon was runter was ich
irgendwie fangen kann oder so ich sehe
jetzt gerade nichts ähm ich gehe mal
ganz kurz eben wieder so ein bisschen
Koppel Stone Farmen während ich euch
erzähle was wir denn heute alles auf der
To-Do-Liste haben zunächst einmal gehe
ich wieder sehr gegangen und gebe es
mittlerweile für dieses Projekt jetzt
erstmal kurz auf einige Kommentare unter
der letzten Folge eine mir geschrieben
wurden und zwar erstmal das hier die
Monster Farben
Challenge habe ich wohl falsch
interpretiert es sollte keine Monster
Farm werden die 24 Blöcke entfernt ist
von unserer Insel sondern die 24 Blöcke
hoch ist vom Boden also von dem
ursprungs-dings hier vorne und ich habe
es halt so gemacht dass ich die 24
Blöcke entfernt habe sie muss allerdings
24 Blöcke hoch sein ich habe das eh
schon hinterfragt warum 24 was ergibt
das denn sind das ist tatsächlich damit
die Tiere also Tiere Spawner nicht
sondern Monster damit die Monster die
dort spawnen tatsächlich so viel falsch
Schaden bekommen dass sie mit einem Kind
zu töten sind und das war so ein
bisschen die ja der Sinn hinter dieser
Challenge das habe ich nicht so ganz
verstanden ich würde trotzdem durchgehen
lassen weil ich werde die Monster fahren
auf Dauer eh noch mal umbauen dafür
brauche ich allerdings wie bereits der
letzten und auch vorletzten Folge schon
gesagt deutlich mehr Holz ich ähm ich
habe auch noch einen anderen Kommentar
geschrieben bekommen den blende ich euch
jetzt mal eben ganz kurz an und zwar
ging es darum diese Leuchten da wurde
nämlich gesagt luca du kannst die
unteren zwei drei Blöcke weg
und jetzt ist gar nichts passiert
außer das ist halt weg ist
allerdings soll das angeblich jetzt
nachwachsen und das können wir einfach
mal abwarten und dann habe ich wieder
eine Chance dass hier vielleicht was
wächst meine Spitzhacke ist fast kaputt
da vorne sind Sticks runtergefallen dass
leadert uns tatsächlich auch schon zum
nächsten Kommentar der mir auch
freundlicherweise von euch unten in die
Kommentare geschrieben wurde und zwar
der nächste ist gewachsen
was geht los das Glück kommt zurück
meine Damen und Herren äh das brauche
ich mal ganz schnell direkt ab das ist
nichts gedroppt bevor da irgendwas in
die Lava direkt einfällt und wir gehen
auch mal direkt welche fast gerade
runter gesetzt ähm geh doch mal direkt
in den Baum den mal ganz kurz ab also
was mir auch noch geschrieben oder was
ich gerade bereits sagen wollte war das
hier Luca bitte heizt doch nicht mehr
weiterhin wenn du mal was verbrennst im
Ofen mit Holz sondern ähm mach dir
Holzkohle und das kann ich anscheinend
so machen indem ich hier einen Schlamm
rein packe beispielsweise hier so ein
Brett und jetzt kommt hier vorne ich leg
mal direkt ein paar rein dass ich schaue
dass ich das hier komplett ausnutzen mit
dem Holz jetzt kommt ihr tatsächlich
Holzkohle raus und diese Holzkohle kann
ich jetzt nehmen und eine Holzkohle hat
eine verbrennt seit von acht
Blöcken oder so keine Ahnung oh es geht
wieder zurück das heißt es hat jetzt gar
nichts gebracht das ist ja mehr
reingelegt habe allerdings äh kriegen
wir dann tatsächlich irgendwie mehr raus
und sparen dadurch noch mal Materialien
die wisst ihr das Ressourcen Materialien
hier das allerwichtigste in diesem
Projekt sind ich habe mich auch ein
bisschen schlau gemacht vor dieser Folge
wie wir das mit einem starterhaus so ein
bisschen hinkriegen sollen weil ich
brauche ja langsam mal ein Häuschen also
gut ich brauche es nicht wir können es
auch ein paar Folgen bauen aktuell
reicht diese Kiste erstmal noch
vollkommen aus für alle Sachen die ich
aktuell habe mehr besitzt sich ja gerade
nicht äh jedoch habe ich auch bockenhaus
bauen ich habe auch schon coole Ideen
allerdings brauche ich echt mehr
Materialien und ich brauche Fichten
deswegen ist heute unser Ziel dorthin zu
gehen und in der Nacht die ja gerade
schon ist
vielleicht das ein oder andere Monster
zu sehen von daher meine Damen und
Herren
die Sonne ist untergegangen der Mond ist
aufgegangen
ich werde mich jetzt zum allerersten Mal
im Projekt Skyblock mit Luca daran
bewegen hier ein Schwert zu machen
um
ich habe sie nicht vermisst
ich habe die wirklich nicht vermisst
aber
wir dürfen
wir dürfen keine Angst haben die
Monsters bauen auf jeden Fall das heißt
die Plattform funktioniert das
wichtigste was ich jetzt mal machen
möchte ist das hier und zwar soll das
jetzt erstmal ein Lager vorher sein und
unser erster richtiger Spot also dass
wir uns schon wieder
gesehen er hat mich gesehen okay okay
es vorne nur Zombies okay es darf
allerdings es darf keiner sterben also
doch also die sollen sterben aber die
dürfen mich nicht groß angreifen weil
ich darf ja dann nachher nicht von der
Insel absichtlich runter
oh mein Gott da ist einiges gesprochen
auf unserer Plattform wir müssen uns auf
jeden Fall so ein bisschen absichern ähm
wir dürfen auf jeden Fall nicht so viel
Dings verlieren nicht so viel Hunger und
das Recht keine Herzen das ist auf Dauer
dann nur noch schlimmer ich
[Musik]
es funktioniert und da sind Spinnen das
heißt die droppen Seide und aus Seide
können wir uns wolle machen und dann ein
Bett craften ja ich weiß wir können auch
da ganz hinten zu der Plattform hin das
haben wir auch einige von euch schon
geschrieben aber ich will es eigentlich
lieber auf diese Art und Weise machen
okay
okay ich gehe erst mal ich gehe erstmal
auf safe
ich mache erstmal
wie mache ich das denn ich habe nicht
meine Mauern es geht los es geht los mit
den Zombies es geht los mit den Monstern
ich brauche Pfeil und Bogen ich brauche
ich brauche ein Bett und die Nacht
zwischen und ich brauche erst rechts
Skelette und da sind keine Skelette ich
brauche Knochen mehr so doll ich brauche
was zu essen ich muss das ja alles ich
hätte nicht gedacht dass es sich so
lange zieht danke für den Stock sehr
sehr lieb habe ich einen Setzling
bekommen bisher auch noch nicht ich will
doch gar nicht gucken nee der liegt
nichts mehr ich habe auch ein bisschen
Schiss da vorne von den ganzen Leuten ne
boah mein Ziel war es eigentlich dahin
heute hinzugehen zum Fichtenbaum aber
jetzt traue ich mich das nicht mehr ich
möchte auf jeden Fall jetzt erstmal ganz
kurz das hier so ein bisschen größer
machen denn ihr wisst ja ich möchte
generell auf Dauer eigentlich alles
soweit es geht mit Erde voll haben weil
ich einfach am schönsten finde ihr wisst
ich habe in Minecraft mit Luca Staffel 1
und auch Staffel 2 ist immer total
gemocht mit der Natur zusammen irgendwas
zu bauen sei es in Staffel 2 die
Hobbithöhle gewesen oder in Staffel 1
auch beispielsweise dass ich einfach auf
dieser Insel war ein kleines Haus gebaut
habe und dann eher noch so ein See und
eine Farm daneben ist doch irgendwer mit
rübergekommen schaut euch das mal an
das sind ja mittlerweile auch Skelette
wir müssen es irgendwie hinkriegen dass
nur Skelette rüberkommen ich versuche es
jetzt wenn ein Creeper kommt
ist das Ganze am Arsch ich beweg mich
ganz langsam vor
ich weiß nicht auf welche Entfernung die
mich sehen wenn ein Creeper von denen
checkt
dass ich rüber laufe
gehen Skelette schon die spawnt das
Skelett da ist aber im nächsten ich gehe
jetzt mal ein bisschen davon ich habe
Angst dass dieser Creeper mich gleich
entdeckt
aber das Skelette kann mich doch
eigentlich auf eine weitere Entfernung
sehen oder wegen dem Bogen und so boah
ich bewege mich immer näher
ich sehe aber kein Enderman mehr
das heißt es gibt nichts was ich
angucken kann
[Musik]
nein nein
der Weg ist kaputt
und beide Skelette sind runter aber gut
okay
das heißt zumindest dass kein Wort
Monster erstmal rüberkommen kann boah
hey habe ich noch einen Setzling
irgendwo dann kann ich noch irgendwo
jetzt wird wirklich spannend hier
mittlerweile jetzt wo die Monster mit da
sind jetzt geht's los und ich habe von
keinem der beiden Bäume in setzting
bekommen ich habe mich zu Beginn so
gefreut dass ihr Bäume wachsen aber ich
habe keinen einzigen setzen bekommen ey
wir haben nur noch diese drei ich fühle
mich so als drehen wir uns im Kreis
aktuell boah aber gut okay ich ähm habe
ich noch Erde irgendwo ich habe hier
noch viel Erde ich möchte auf jeden Fall
ein Lagerfeuer bauen ähm ich setze das
jetzt erstmal hier hin ich habe aber
auch hier wieder Angst dass das rüber
Switch auf den Baum und dann brennt oh
ich habe so wenig Ahnung von Minecraft
in der neue Skelette nee das war nur
dieser komische setzen da vorne ich weiß
noch nicht ob der setzt den wachsen kann
der Keimling da oder was anderes
[Musik]
drei neue Zombies und noch mehr
ich muss es wirklich so machen dass die
der kann mich von da schon sehen
und wenn ich alles sicher was ich habe
ist ja egal komm mal ein bisschen Action
hier
die Plattform kaputt mir egal schau mal
[Musik]
ja gut irgendwie oh mein Gott
alles von denen runter außer die
Skelette oh mein Gott das ist die Idee
Skelette
das wäre so krass denn ist noch ein
Creeper den Krieg ich aber
runtergeschlagen dann hätte ich
zumindestens Skelett und hätte einen
Knochenmehl um zumindest neues Gras zu
machen ich riskiere es
[Musik]
oh mein Gott
ich muss ihn töten
ich musste das Gerät töten
ich werde sonst selbst gestorben
ich dachte ich könnte ein bisschen
ausweichen aber der ist ja extra zur
Kante gegangen ich muss das hier glaube
ich ein Zäunen mit Mauern ich muss ja
auf jeden Fall erstmal weg
ich hatte so viele andere Pläne für
diese Folge
und nichts von dem was ich mir
vorgenommen habe habe ich bisher gemacht
das Lagerfeuer okay
aber sonst wirklich nichts
ich will nach dahinten
ich komme da auch heute noch in die
Sonne geht ja kann das ja schon sehen
die Sonne geht hier vorne geht gleich
schon wieder auf aber ich muss jetzt
erstmal meine hungerkeulen auffüllen
kann ich was ist denn wenn ich das jetzt
esse was passiert dann dann kriege ich
nur noch mehr Hunger oder ich habe jetzt
Hunger für 28 Sekunden wenn man auf eine
Hunger Keulen unten gucken die gehen
schon wieder zurück okay das macht es
auch nicht besser dann bräuchte ich mehr
verrotte das Fleisch ich hätte die
Zombies runterladen ist schon wieder was
ist denn
es ist stressig ich weiß nicht ob ich in
der heutigen Folge bisher ein Cut
gemacht habe oder so ey ich brauche
jetzt auch nee oder jetzt habe ich jetzt
wieder reicht die noch für drei Steine
eins komm bitte lass mich nicht im Stich
jetzt kaputt gehen nicht komm bitte nein
okay sehr gut drei Steine habe ich noch
rausgekriegt das heißt ich kann mir auf
jeden Fall eine neue steinspitzhacke
machen und muss ich jetzt wieder den
Umweg gehen
Umweg gehen boah perfekt jetzt ist sie
kaputt gegangen zumindest ein bisschen
Glück da muss ich wieder den Umweg gehen
und meine holzspitzhacke hey komm mach
mal ein bisschen
schönere Musik bisschen besser drauf ich
meine wir können ja theoretisch das
ganze auch so angehen dass wir
vielleicht uns hinstellen an die Mob
fahren warten des Tages bis die alle
verbrennen und vielleicht droppt uns ein
Skelett dann irgendwie Knochen aber ich
weiß auch nicht ob Skelette Knochen
droppen wenn man sie nicht tötet
allerdings sehen wir schon im
Hintergrund hier vorne die Sonne geht
auf da vorne das heißt es könnte machbar
sein wir haben allerdings kein Skelett
ich werde mich noch mal ein bisschen
näher da vorne hinbewegen machen jetzt
erstmal ein paar Buchstaben dann schauen
wir uns das mal an ich hätte auch Schiss
dass mich das Geld dann abschießt weil
wir haben kein Skelett nee
[Musik]
aber hätte auf zu brennen okay
wir haben wirklich nichts
[Musik]
komm bitte Drop ein bisschen Fleisch ich
kann den Weg ich kann aber das so machen
nein nein
nee oder ey das ist doch wirklich das
ist wieder eine Schwachsinns Folge hier
äh
das war unser Fleisch
ey das hat mir so gebraucht ich habe
eine hungerkeule wenn ich ja gut aber wo
soll ich denn runterfallen ne das
einzige wenn ich hier runterfallen bin
ich tot oh ey das ist so ich hätte nicht
gedacht dass es so schlimm wird dir es
tut mir einfach ich bin so schlecht in
diesem
ich wollte mit meinem kleinen
fingerschiff drücken damit ich mich
Sneaker aber aus Versehen auf ich habe
außerdem Steuerung gedrückt jetzt bin
ich gelaufen oh mein Gott wenn ich jetzt
es ich drücke jetzt nur escape ne
wenn ich jetzt das Geld zurück runter
[Musik]
oh mein Gott
was ist das für eine Folge
ich checks nicht Leute
das ist die verrückteste Skyblock mit
Luca Folge ist komplett Projekt bisher
hey no joke es sieht auch echt schon
wird aus mittlerweile hier bei uns so
ein bisschen ich hätte zu Beginn nicht
gedacht dass es sich so entwickelt aber
das ist sehr cool auch irgendwie dass
man es nicht so ganz vorhersehen kann
eigentlich will ich jetzt auf Dauer hier
diese Mauern auch noch wegnehmen und
dann hier vorne so ein offeneren Bereich
machen die könnte ich auch theoretisch
wegnehmen damit ich die dahinten setze
aber dann sind da wieder Creeper und
hauen das in die Luft ich muss wirklich
die mobben deutlich höher bauen dafür
brauche ich allerdings wirklich erstmal
Holz und bei mir wächst nichts und ich
weiß nicht warum aber ich will auch
nicht cheaten ich will jetzt kein Holz
machen ich kann einfach nur hoffen dass
wenn ich da hinten hingehen komm ich
mache jetzt meine timelaps ey wir müssen
erstmal wirklich boah ich muss auch
erstmal ganz kurz chillen ne erst mal
kurz abbauen
[Musik]
oh es ist genau kaputt gegangen wo ich
gerade gesehen hab oh
zwei Bäume das Glück ist zurück meine
Damen und ich sag's wie es jetzt so
nehmen wir uns hier direkt die Steinaxt
was ich mir übrigens auch gedacht habe
ist erstmal deswegen habe ich auch zu
Lagerfeuer gemacht hast habe ich vorhin
gar nicht zu Ende ausgesprochen wenn wir
noch mehr Erde haben hier halt alles
aber voll zu machen mit Erde und dann
hier vorne in der Erde das Lagerfeuer
hinzusetzen mit der Schaufel dann
Rechtsklick auf dem Boden dann haben wir
wieder so einen Weg zum Lagerfeuer dann
machen wir uns einfach so ein Lagerfeuer
weil so ein Haus ich hatte zwar auch
viele Ideen warte ich mache mir erstmal
jetzt wirklich bevor wir jetzt irgendwie
was hier verschwenden oder so alles
erstmal zu Bruch Dingern sag das reicht
auch gleich damit wir zur Insel gehen
das ist auch gewachsen hoffe ich traust
mich allerdings
von daher erstmal hier alles kurz ein
bisschen ausgleichst dann so dass auch
wirklich nichts verloren geht wenn der
Baum hier irgendwas droppen sollte weil
das halt ja passen oder komm wir gehen
sogar noch einen Schritt weiter so das
sollte jetzt glaube ich hinhauen genau
dann wollte ich so ein kleines
Lagerfeuer machen so ein lagercamp das
hatten wir ja bei Minecraft mit Luca
Staffel 1 auch auf unserer Tierinsel
tatsächlich ich vermisse dieses Projekt
zu doll und ich bin auch ganz ehrlich da
muss also muss ich auch einfach ganz
realistisch sein zum Projekt wird es
kein zweites Mal geben nicht auf meinem
Kanal ich hätte das Projekt auch einfach
länger ziehen können auch oft bis Folge
150 oder 200 aber ich finde das habt ihr
auch oft schon ein reactions und
generell kennt ja auch meine Ansicht bei
solchen Themen ich bin da relativ strikt
wenn was geil ist so lieber die Leute
meiner Ansicht nach so ein bisschen
gesättigt lassen so mäßig als zu sagen
aber meine Spitzhacke ist kaputt oh
meine Spitzhacke ist kaputt ich Nulli
und jetzt habe ich schon wieder alles zu
Stein hey ich bin wieder so ein Trottel
ich werde es nie lernen muss mir wieder
eine holzspitzhacke machen
naja ich bin ein Fan davon lieber die
Leute also euch so ein bisschen
gesättigt lassen wisst ihr anstatt dass
ihr zu oft geil wir haben noch einen
Setzling anstatt das unten Apfel boah
der ist Suppe der ist so wichtig gerade
unser Essen wieder auffüllen okay besser
als ich noch okay geil jetzt werde ich
es tatsächlich auch so machen dass ich
meine Erde nehme die ich ja noch hier
vorne habe und werde jetzt erstmal in
diesem Bereich hier noch ein Baum setzen
nämlich genau hier hin dann werde ich
mal genau hier noch einen hinsetzen an
der genug Platz ich weiß es nicht sonst
können wir auch wir machen es mal so
eben jetzt mal den einen hör hatte ich
noch aber vielleicht kriegen wir da
hinten noch einen raus ist hier noch
einer nee ähm ich finde es immer
sinnvoller die Leute also euch in dem
Sinne so ein bisschen gesättigt sage ich
mal ähm rauszugehen soll leicht hungrig
noch rausgehen zu lassen als ähm jetzt
übelst keine Ahnung und dann hat
irgendwann keinen Bock auf das Projekt
und dann hat man da weiß ich nicht weil
ich gucke aktuell diese Serie Manifest
auf Netflix ich weiß nicht ob die kennt
irgendwie Skyblock mit Luca auch so ein
laberprojekt geworden ne bei Minecraft
gleichzeitig so viele Möglichkeiten habe
ich ja gar nicht so viele Möglichkeiten
deswegen quatsche ich ein bisschen mehr
zu mein Livestream auf Youtube und nicht
live na ja ähm auf jeden Fall gucke ich
aktuell diese Serie Manifest und ich
hasse es wenn Serien so künstlich in die
Länge gezogen werden nur weil es gut
läuft man schaut euch mal Prison Break
an z.B oder Schreck oder solche Banner
also ne so banale Serien ja auch das ist
schon echt irgendwie ekelhaft finde ich
meine Ansicht nach wenn da der Profit
über dem Projekt steht und ähm genau
deswegen wollte ich einfach mit
Minecraft mit Luca Staffel 1 und kleines
Zeichen setzen okay Folge 100 gibt es
auch noch eine Menge Sachen die wir
machen können aber wir beenden den
ganzen Lachs und äh ich weiß gar nicht
mehr wie ich jetzt auf das Thema
gekommen bin aber Dinge ist es auf jeden
Fall ich habe auf jeden Fall jetzt mal
ganz kurz wieder äh Einstein nur das
heißt ich brauche noch eben kurz zwei
weiter ab so dass ich mir zumindest eine
steinspitzhacke wieder machen kann ich
sie auch da vorne die Sonne neigt sich
schon wieder dem Ende zu das heißt wir
haben gleich auch wieder ein Problem
hinsichtlich Monster da vorne deswegen
werde ich da auch direkt gleich mal
wieder den Weg abschnüren um einfach
erstmal hier das Holz sichern und vor
allem erstmal die Erde sichern da vorne
fallen trotzdem Sachen oder aber wir
haben zwei neue Dinge das ist sehr sehr
wild sogar noch mehr oder drei neue
Setzlinge sogar um auf Nummer safe Safe
zu gehen ich weiß kein Monster kann
wirklich springen aber ich brauche jetzt
erstmal beide ab ähm und jetzt hole ich
mal eben kurz die Erde Pflanze den Baum
dann noch mal hin hier und hier pflanze
ich auch noch mal ein oder wir machen es
tatsächlich so dass ich alles hier vorne
hin baue falls das reicht vom Platz hier
einer hin
hier sollte auch noch einer hin können
und dann bauen wir einfach mal hier
vorne auch noch einen hin jetzt haben
wir auf jeden Fall schon mal ein paar
Sätze Dinge und ein paar Bäume die
wachsen können vielleicht kommt da sogar
auch noch einer raus vielleicht kommt da
vorne auch noch was raus gibt davon was
er da liegen noch Sticks ich esse auch
mal eben kurz den Apfel oder hatte ich
Dir nicht ich habe den schon gegessen
nee gib mir das jetzt gar nichts
gebracht oder bin ich gerade wieder
gespendet ich weiß es nicht auf jeden
Fall habe ich echt komplett den Faden
verloren das ist mega entspannt gut ähm
ich werde mir auf jeden Fall in der
nächsten Folge dann die ganze Erde und
so da vorne nee wir gehen jetzt noch
darüber
wir lassen die Erde hier und das Holz
und ich nehme
nämlich noch ich nehme keine Fackel mit
ich verstehe auch dieses Ding also ich
verstehe es wirklich nicht euch
ich muss eine Fackel mitnehmen
was ist wenn der Hund Monsters bauen
weil ich werde in der Nacht egal Norris
no fun das ist mein Motto
[Applaus]
[Musik]
okay Freunde ich habe alle
bruchsteinstufen verbaut und bin
tatsächlich noch nicht angekommen wir
haben allerdings schon einen Klaus ist
leider keine Kiste daneben sondern
wirklich ein Kürbis
ich weiß nicht was ich mit dem Kürbis
soll aber gut ähm ist das ein virenbusch
davor kann auch seine haben wir
vielleicht noch ein paar Bären ähm es
reicht auf jeden Fall nicht aus und das
Problem ist auch dass ich jetzt gerade
nicht sprinten möchte weil sonst haben
wir noch mehr hungerkeulen verloren
deswegen würde ich sagen ich blende euch
jetzt tatsächlich noch mal
time ich da hinten hin laufe und noch
ein paar Steine
[Musik]
nee oder nein nein ihr blöden ja dann
bringt mich halt um es mehr egal
jetzt ist wirklich Quatsch das hier
wieder ankommen ich habe ey sorry
wirklich ich habe doch ich kam doch
schon mal was wollt ihr denn jetzt noch
hier oh mein Gott
den Sekunden später auch essen irgendwie
so phantomfleisch das ist eigentlich
sogar echt lachig man muss halt nur
gucken wann die kommen ne tschüss
tschüss
hä das ist ja dann erzählt
phantomhaut was können wir damit machen
können wir das Essen wir haben drei Mal
eine Phantom Haut kann ich nee kann ich
nicht essen mach die irgendwas ich weiß
er schreibt immer gerne in die
Kommentare was ich mit einer Phantom
ausmachen soll ich bin jetzt zwar
gestorben aber wieder nur vier leben
vier Herzen ich weiß ja nicht das sieht
mir alles ein bisschen zu eng aus mit
dem Bäumen aber ich bin ganz ehrlich
leute ich kann nicht mehr
ich kann nicht mehr
[Musik]
ich kann wirklich nicht mehr das ist das
wie kannst du einmal riskieren
ich wir können es noch einmal kurz
riskieren
[Musik]
so haben wir die Spitzhacke auch noch
mal kurz leer gemacht da vorne ist
richtig Party
also da geht es wirklich übertrieben ab
allerdings werde ich erstmal hier meine
ganzen Bruchsteine wieder zu Bruchstein
Stufen machen bzw so ein paar lasse ich
mir übrig drei Stück damit ich mir eine
neue Spitzhacke machen kann das auf
jeden Fall sinnvoll zack zack dann mache
ich mir die auch mal eben BAM und BAM
spitzhack ist fertig das habe ich das
habe ich die Erde packe ich mal weg habe
ich noch irgendwo zwei Bäume sind
gewachsen okay gut ich habe auch gerade
ehrlich gesagt sechs Minuten abgebaut
also da kann man noch mal erwarten dass
ein bisschen was weg ne wenn ich Bäume
noch mal eben kurz abbauen es geht jetzt
eigentlich die ganze Zeit ja erstmal so
weiter falls das jetzt nicht äh nicht
falsch betrachte hier gerade weil ich
einfach jetzt Holz fahren muss und
Steine Farben erstmal Materialien zu
kriegen um dann schluss endlich äh die
Opfern weiterzubauen um dann Knochenmehl
zu bekommen um dann mit dem Knochenmehl
als darf nichts Lagerfeuer reinfallen ne
perfekt
perfekt geht aber auch was kaputt wenn
man da was rein schmeiß ich teste mal
mit seiner bruchsteinstufe der gut die
könnt ihr nicht verbrennen oder ist der
Stein theoretisch
ich habe die bleibt wirklich drauf
liegen ich glaube das Feuer macht nichts
weil in Lava geht das ja kaputt ja geht
kaputt naja die Sonne geht auf
[Musik]
immer wieder schön hey ganz ehrlich der
Baum hier ist jetzt auf jeden Fall auch
abgebaut das heißt der wird ja auch die
Sachen droppen das wird ja auch
hinfallen ich muss die Folge und werde
die Folge auch auf jeden Fall so lange
erstmal noch laufen lassen weil das ist
wieder eine absolute Überlänge Folge
weil die Skelette dürfen nicht zu nah
kommen da darf nicht runterfallen da ist
was runtergefallen irgendwas ist da
runtergefallen dass das eine Skelett
musst du auf jeden Fall drauf bleiben es
darf nicht mit auf diesen Ebenen äh auf
diesen kleinen fahrt ihr so die Zombie
sterben jetzt jeden Moment und dann
bitte auch das gleiche Zombies tot okay
das ist ein Stück Fleisch das können wir
auf jeden Fall essen okay haben wir
unseren ersten Clown ich sehe unseren
ersten Knochen ich zufällig sind zwei
Knochen oh mein Gott es sind zwei
Knochen sehr gut sehr gut nicht sprinten
Luca verrottetes Fleisch essen guck mal
wer braucht seine Monster fahren wenn
man so eine Taktik hat wie ich einfach
zwei Blöcke Platz lassen so und dann
einfach abwarten guck mal nach vorne
droppen Setzlinge ey Leute die Folge ist
so bescheuert gestartet dann Apfel auch
noch es läuft immer besser hier auch
noch und setzting ey Leute es geht los
Skyblock mit Luca geht los meine Hunger
Herzen fühlen sie sich wieder auf ich
weiß nicht wenn jetzt noch Weizen
rauskommt guck mal Weizen und drei
Weizenkörner es geht los meine Damen und
Herren we are of back meine Damen und
Herren so hier vorne anpflanzen
anpflanzen anpflanzen dort zack zack
zack das hier vorne mal wieder weg da
kann ich wieder weg so kann erstmal
nichts drauf wachsen da warten jetzt
erstmal kurz ab da vorne ist noch auf
keinen Fall die spawnen wir brauchen
jeden Setzling irgendwie kriegen können
wir haben zwei Stück allein schon hier
da vorne können auch noch was rauskommen
setz dich mal direkt wieder hier neben
noch ein Setzling noch mal Stecker
ich werde hier vorne auch direkt mal
noch mal ein Baum drauf Pflanzen BAM ey
das ist so ein richtiges Livestream
Projekt eigentlich egal lade ich halt
lange Youtube Videos wo mir auch egal
wie bereits gesagt das ist kein Projekt
wo ich jetzt irgendwie sagt hey guck mal
Speedrun ich will die voll schnell alles
irgendwie fertig machen in der ersten
Folge haben direkt die Monster fahren
und diese und das es soll ganz entspannt
werden dass wir vorne kann ich auch noch
mal eben kurz abtragen so wenn wir ganz
viele Baustellen mittlerweile die Baum
fahren konnten die wird immer größer
machen in der nächsten Folge
was runter egal wir sind nicht mehr so
doll darauf angewiesen dass hier vorne
wächst ich werde noch mal eben kurz das
hier die Knochen nämlich zu Knochen mir
machen so dass wir
ich bin ein Schatten gerade von
irgendwas gesehen ich glaube das war der
setzt den hier vorne den werde ich auch
noch mal eben schnell anpflanzen ich
hätte auch noch Zeit da hinten rüber zu
gehen was machen wir dann nächsten Folge
wir machen sie nächste Folge ich habe
keine Erde habe ich hier noch Erde ja
zwei Stück habe ich noch dann kann ich
auf jeden Fall ich werde hier vorne
waren in der Pflanze keinen Baum mehr an
wir brauchen eine größere Fläche für die
Bäume auf jeden Fall das ist blöd dass
jetzt wir machen in der nächsten Folge
ah nee das schaffen wir wieder zeitlich
nicht ich brauche auch hier eine Insel
Reparatur Folge Leute Minecraft Staffel
1 da hatten wir eine Insel Reparatur das
brauchen wir auch hier
das ist nicht schön
ich sag sie sitzt schaut euch das mal an
wirklich da krieg ich
Kotzreiz hier vorne ist noch ein
Setzling gedroppt den haben wir auch ich
habe auch noch ein Erdblock das heißt
ich kann sogar irgendwo noch einen
witzigen hinsetzen ich mache jetzt
einfach mal hier auf die Kante ich weiß
nicht ob da wachsen wird weil hier vorne
der ja auf der Höhe ist aber wir setzen
einfach mal alles hier hin da vorne nee
da vorne ist glaube ich ein sinnvoller
Platz ich traue mich aber jetzt gerade
nicht den abzubauen weil ich wirklich
nichts verschwenden weil wir haben aber
bisher auch nichts zu großartig verkackt
glaube ich aber gut wir nehmen jetzt
erstmal das Knochenmehl gönnen uns das
hier drauf boah
mich aber gerade hier ein bisschen ne
[Musik]
so kann das Lagerfeuer schön nach oben
ablüften boah das ist echt schön
alles so ein bisschen voll mit Gras aber
wir dürfen es nicht lange genießen denn
wir brauchen tatsächlich Weizenkörner da
haben wir einen rausbekommen hier auch
noch mal guck mal dann können wir dann
nächste Folge auf unsere Farben machen
hier vorne haben wir keinen mehr
rausbekommen noch mal drauf ach guck mal
noch eine Blume zack hier vorne noch mal
so ein bisschen ey das ist doch Wahnsinn
guck mal ich habe nicht mal die Monster
getötet sondern die haben sich selber
getötet und dann allein dadurch habe ich
jetzt diese Weizenkörner bekommen ey das
ist doch Hammer guck mal hier vorne so
ein bisschen ich werde jetzt auch mal so
machen glaube ich dass ich das hier
erstmal wieder wegnehme und ich werde
hier vorne ich habe ja noch eine
Schaufel hier glaube ich am Start ja
genau die habe ich auch äh jetzt werde
ich zwar so machen dass ich das Wasser
hier an der Seite her fließen lasse so
so dann machen wir hier jetzt brauchen
wir hier natürlich wieder Kabel Stone so
ein bisschen damit es halt anpflanzen
können weil dann kann ich halt hier
alles anpflanzen so drumherum
dann mache ich ich mache es aber glaube
ich erstmal so weil so viele
Weizenkörner haben wir jetzt eh nicht
zack zack wir werden allerdings noch ein
paar bekommen hier vorne noch mal eben
abbauen da haben wir schon wieder zwei
neue BAM wir haben schon viel und dann
haben wir endlich auch eine Futterquelle
Leute ich sag's euch jetzt ich mache das
jetzt endlich macht dabei immer noch
eben kurz die endcard ihr merkt glaube
ich wie viel bockig auf dieses Projekt
habe ich will einfach weiter durchziehen
ich will jetzt Vorankommen es geht
endlich los und wir brauchen einmal
Sonne Folge wo ganz ganz viel passiert
damit es in Fahrt kommt deswegen wenn es
euch gefallen hat lasst gerne einen
Daumen hoch unter dem Video hier da
abonniert meinen Kanal um weitere Folgen
Skyblock mit Luca nicht zu verpassen und
noch viel wichtiger Klick auf die Glocke
damit ihr eine Benachrichtigung bekommt
wenn ich was neues hochlade kann ich den
jetzt schon umstülpen ja das geht schon
okay mache ich das noch mal eben und
mache hier vorne auch noch mal zack
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht wann es weitergeht
irgendwann die Tage
[Musik]
ich kann euch einfach nur sagen
abonniert den Channel wenn ihr das
weiter hier sehen wollt und dann gehen
wir in der nächsten Folge rüber zu der
Insel dahinten gönnen uns die Erde und
den Fichtenbaum und wir bauen hier ein
vernünftiges Feld
ich nehme schon wieder zu viel vor weil
ich denke gerade schon wie weit könnten
auch noch ein See bauen aber gut
ich will am liebsten das jetzt noch ein
Baum wächst dass ich noch irgendwas
machen kann jetzt geht's los ich habe
richtig Bock ich habe richtig ich darf
nicht ich bin
knappen Stunde mittlerweile haut rein
habe ich die ciao
[Musik]